we met a little girl
and she was a fan of
and she's just getting started doing you
two
she travel
what advice would you give to young
right so I what what I do is I don't
want
don't want any of this what I do is I do
what I'm passionate about I do what I
share my life and I'm open and honest
about it so if people if people shared
with people shared themselves if they
gave their heart to the camera to the
community I think it's powerful that's
that's what people are drawn to so just
give give up yourself and don't do
because you want to be rich or famous or
you know that I mean do it because
you're passionate about it and you love
it and you're making your art
is there any like
about what people that have been
I don't know about the don'ts but the
dues is like what here's the thing I
broke all the rules you know I didn't I
mean it's it's different for me though
because I saw God and put a video put on
YouTube but everyone else its work you
just you just got to work the community
you got to be friendly you got to go out
there and the bottom line is you got to
create content that's interesting and
people want to watch if you don't have
that then you can't do anything but on
top of that then you got to go to
network you gotta you know show it to
other people and it's it's all just work
it's not how I did it but I cheated
you